انتهت للتو جهود الإنقاذ في
مدينة هيكوري بوسط أوكرانيا في
أعقاب موجة من الضربات الصاروخية الروسية
خلال الليل، ويقول مسؤولون محليون إن
خمسة مواقع مدنية أصيبت، بما في ذلك
مبنى سكني، مما أسفر عن مقتل ما لا يقل عن 11
شخصًا وإصابة العشرات.
الرئيس الأوكراني لفلاديمير
زيلينسكي نشر  هذا الفيديو على
صفحته على البرقية،
يطالب كيث في هذه الأثناء بمزيد من المكاسب
في الجنوب مع استمرار القتال العنيف
هناك وفي الشرق في
المنطقة التالية، ينضم إلي سام كايلي من CNN
على الهواء مباشرة من كيث، كيف تصف
هذه المرحلة من الهجوم المضاد سام ويل
ماكس  ما رأيناه في كريف هو
المزيد من المحاولات الروسية للعودة
إلى اليوم الأول من الحرب حقا
لاستهداف المدنيين هذه المرة
عفوا في المدينة الأوكرانية الوسطى
مدينة صناعية كبيرة بها
أه صناعة الصلب
واحتياطي المياه وقدرات توليدية مهمة جدا  وما إلى ذلك،
ولكنه مبنى سكني
تم استهدافه مما أسفر عن مقتل 11 شخصًا وإصابة أكثر من عشرين آخرين
في كارثة مدنية أخرى، كل
هذا يحدث بينما
أعتقد أنه يمكننا القول بأمان
الآن أن الأوكرانيين يشنون هجومًا مضادًا
مع زيادة كبيرة في
محاولاتهم  لاختراق
الخطوط الروسية في جنوب البلاد
بين زاباريسيا ومدينة
دانيت (التي كانت تحت سيطرة القوات الروسية)،
وردت تقارير عن
تقدم تدريجي في تلك المنطقة من قبل
القوات الأوكرانية باستخدام الكثير من المعدات التي
تبرعت بها  الناتو وحتمًا
بعض الخسائر في كل من الأفراد وتلك
المعدات وفي نفس الوقت
ربما يكون هناك اتصال ولكن أعتقد أن
العمليات المتقدمة غير المتصلة التي يجريها
الأوكرانيون جنوب باكمود أعتقد
أن هذه كانت فرصة حيث كان
الروس يتراجعون في
تواجه روسيا
الهجمات المضادة الأوكرانية في جزء من مد وجزر
القتال الدائر
هناك، لكن لا شك أنهم
سيستفيدون بلا شك من
الأوكرانيين ويدمجونه في
تخطيطهم لهذا الهجوم الأوسع الذي
أعتقد أنه الآن  لا نشهد
الهجوم الكامل بعد، ولكن هناك الكثير من
الاحتياطيات الأوكرانية، ولا يزال هناك الكثير من الأسلحة من نوع الناتو التي لم يتم
طرحها بعد في The
Fray، لكنهم يقولون أيضًا إن هذه
بشكل خاص ستكون
حملة طويلة ودموية ويتوقعون ذلك.
خسائر فادحة للغاية في كلا
الجانبين ماكس